- Hello and welcome everybody.
It's really good to have
you here with us today.
I'm Kim Goff-Crews, I am the
Secretary and Vice President
for University Life here at Yale.
And I'm the University Officer
who leads Belonging at Yale,
which is the university's
activity's actual initiative,
which is designed to enhance
diversity, support equity,
and also promote a sense of wellbeing,
a sense of inclusion and
belonging and welcome
for all of our community members.
Now today's conversation is one
of a series of occasional
conversations that we have
sponsored by Belonging at Yale.
Some of you I know have been with us
in our conversations with
Dolly Chugh or with Ibram Kendi.
Others of you might have joined
the first My Story event that
we had a couple of weeks ago,
where we feature students,
faculty, staff, and alumni,
to talk about their sense
of belonging on campus,
so really interesting event.
So whether you've been with me before
on some of these other events,
or this is your first time,
a hearty welcome to you today.
I do wanna point out that
the Belonging at Yale website
features a lot of calendar,
which have a lot of these events
and some of the taping
of some of the events.
So I ask you to check that
out regularly as well.
But today our conversation is
gonna be really interesting
and very timely and on point.
Respecting all Connecticut families,
the legal parent-child
relationship for unmarried,
same sex and non-biological parents.
This is a topic that's actually
interesting for everybody.
But I'm particularly
glad to host this event
this month in April, when
we celebrate LGBTQ PRIDE.
In conversation today,
our two of our Yale community members,
a faculty and staff member.
Douglas NeJaime who teaches
at the Yale Law School
is with us.
He is the Anne Urowsky Professor of Law,
and he has a secondary
appointment by the way,
at the Yale Child Study Center.
Doug teaches courses on
professional responsibility,
family law, the
constitution of both family
and also law and sexuality.
But he is for today's
purposes, the principal drafter
of the Connecticut Parentage Act.
That act for those of you don't know,
passed with near unanimous support,
which is hard to do nowadays,
so really well done, Doug,
near unanimous support from
Connecticut legislators
and it was signed into law
by the Governor in 2021.
He is going to be in conversation
with Deb Stanley-McAulay
who is the Associate Vice President
for Employee Engagement
and Workplace Culture.
Many of us know that Deb
oversees the Office of
Diversity and Inclusion,
Work Life and Childcare programs,
and is also the key person responsible
for New Haven Hiring Initiative.
And she is also the chief liaison
for all of our affinity groups.
So with that, I'm looking
forward to this conversation
as many of you are,
and I'm gonna turn it
over to Debbie and Doug.
- Welcome everyone, and a
particular welcome to you, Doug.
Thanks for agreeing to be
in conversation with me.
- Thank you.
- I also understand that you've
agreed to be in conversation
with all of our participants.
So I want to remind
all of our participants
that there's an opportunity for
them to contribute questions
during this presentation and discussion
using the question and answer function
at the bottom of the screen.
So Doug, during our time
together, I've got questions,
a host of questions that are gonna fall
into five different categories.
The first is gonna be a
broad set of questions
that ground us in this discussion.
The second is I'm hoping to delve
into the Connecticut Parentage Act.
And then I thought we'd move
over to maybe understanding
how you were able to get the law passed
and then specifically about
law and your scholarship.
And then finally, I'd love to close us out
with some guidance and some
advice that you might have
that we can implement long
after today's discussion.
So I hope that's the
journey that you're on.
It's the one that I'm hoping
we're gonna go on together.
- Great.
- So let me start, thank you.
Let me start with really a broad question
before we get into the
Connecticut Parentage Act.
Can you just tell us what parentage is?
It's not a term that most of use
with any degree of regularity.
- Yeah, so in some ways a term of art,
but parentage simply refers
to the legal parent-child relationship.
And so our laws have up until this point,
generally use the term
paternity and maternity,
but the gender neutral term, parentage
is what our law is going to
use now simply to describe
the status of being a legal parent
or a child of a legal parent.
- Okay, fantastic and
why is this important?
- Yeah, so a lot comes from having
a legal parent-child relationship,
so there's a host of parental rights
but also responsibilities
that come with parentage.
So if you are a legal parent,
you have decision making
authority to make decisions about
where your child goes to school
and what healthcare your child gets.
And you also, if you and the other person
who might be the parent
aren't living together,
you have the ability to seek custody
or visitation with your child.
You also have an obligation
to financially support your child,
at least until they're 18.
So it's not just rights, it's
important responsibilities.
And then a lot of other benefits
turn on having a legal
parent-child relationship,
federal and state
benefits, social security,
survivor benefits, access to
things like health insurance
for a child.
And so having that legal status
is really important to families.
- Thank you and I imagine that
there are many of our participants
that are probably taking their own notes
because as you and I
engage in conversation,
not only will I walk
away with new knowledge,
I'm hoping they will as well.
So Doug, if we were to turn our attention
specifically to the
Connecticut Parentage Act,
can you give us a brief
summary of what it actually is?
- Yeah, so I guess, let me take off
from what we were just talking about,
which is for most people they
don't have to think twice
about the fact that they're a
legal parent of their child.
And for those folks, this law
doesn't really change much,
but there are a lot of people
in Connecticut and elsewhere
who are raising their child
and yet the law might not
treat them as a legal parent.
And some people are aware of this
and they try and do
things to get around it.
Other people might never know
that they actually
aren't legally recognized
because everyone else is
treating them like a parent.
So what the Connecticut
Parentage Act tries to do
is ensure that all children in
Connecticut have equal access
to the security of that legal
parent-child relationship
by having a more comprehensive
and inclusive parentage
framework in our law
so that people who
otherwise might be treated
as legal strangers to their children,
will now be treated as legal
parents to their children.
So I can walk through a few of the ways
in which that happens.
- That would be very helpful, thank you.
- So for same-sex couples
ordinarily you will have
one of the parents
not have a genetic
connection to the child.
And so if we have a legal framework
that is designed around biology,
which most legal frameworks
around parent-child relationships are,
that means for LGBTQ parents,
half of them are going to
not be treated as parents.
And so we had cases in Connecticut
where you had a same-sex
couple who had a child together
through donor insemination.
So they use donor sperm
and raised the kid together
and then they break up,
let's say the kid's six or eight or 10.
The non-biologic mother had no ability
to even get into court
and say that she was a parent
of the child and seek custody.
And so the law now changes that.
And so now it says, yes,
biology is still a basis
on which to establish parentage,
but there's other basis as well.
And I tend to talk about
these as intent and function.
So intent is take that same sex couple,
they are having a child
together with donor sperm.
They both intend to be
parents of the child,
we should treat them both
as parents of the child.
If a heterosexual, married
couple had a child that way,
our law was treating them both as parents,
we should do the same
thing for same-sex couples
and we should do the same
thing for unmarried couples.
The other dimension is
what I call function.
And that's recognizing someone as a parent
because they're actually
parenting a child,
they've developed a
parent-child relationship.
So we had a wonderful family who testified
in support of the act
and they were a married same-sex couple.
And they had a child
together with donor sperm,
but one the women also had a child
from a previous different
sex relationship.
And that child was three
when the mom got together
with her partner and the child was now 14
when the bill was up and he testified
and supported the bill.
And he had been being
raised by these two moms.
And he called them both mom
and his father wasn't in the picture.
And under our existing law
there was no way for him
to get the security of a legal
parent-child relationship
with his non-biologic mother
and intent wouldn't do him any good
because she wasn't there
when he was conceived.
And so we have now in the law
something called de facto parentage,
which will take effect July 1.
And that's essentially
treating people as parents
because they've developed
a parent-child relationship
and are actually parenting the child.
So overall the act now provides routes
for people to be treated as parents
based on non-biologic factors
like intent and function
or marriage to the birth
parent in a gender neutral way.
- Okay, thank you, Doug.
So Doug, clearly I'm a bit biased
and believe that this was important,
but overall, why was it important
to have this act passed?
- Yeah, so I mean, as I was saying,
a lot of people didn't
have a legal relationship,
but a lot of people were
actually remedying that
by adopting their own children.
So it was really powerful
when the chief probate judge
testified in support of the bill
because the probate court in Connecticut
has jurisdiction over adoptions.
And she came in and said, "I
apologize to these families.
When they come in to adopt their own kids,
they shouldn't have to do this."
And same-sex couples,
if they're being advised
are told do the adoption,
they're still, unfortunately
are gonna be reasons
to think about adoption as an option,
given hostility in other states.
But I think we now have
the tools in Connecticut
to give people the security of parentage
without having to go through
the adoption process.
And it's important
because it also means that
kids will have the security of having
a legal parent-child
relationship so that they have
the right maintain relationships
with their parents.
And if one parent dies,
they aren't then taken
into state custody or
given to a family member,
they're able to stay with their parent.
There's just been too many
heart wrenching cases in which
children's relationships with the people
who are parenting them are
not respected by our law.
And it's important that our
law actually respect families
as they exist in our state.
- Doug, you briefly
mentioned other states.
So I'm wondering if you
could talk with us about
the process prior to
getting this act passed.
In Connecticut were we leading or lagging?
- Yeah, so the act is
modeled on a uniform act,
the Uniform Parentage Act of 2017,
which I was involved with that is put out
by the Uniform Law Commission,
which is a non-partisan
group of law professors,
state lawmakers, state
court judges, and lawyers.
And so that was representing
the new best practices model
and Washington State
adopted a version of it,
Maine, California, Rhode
Island, and Vermont
all adopted versions of it before we did.
But not so bad to be really
in the forefront of that.
And our mission has been
to especially try to make
New England a real zone of equality here.
And so a version of the bill is pending
in Massachusetts right now,
and it is being fiercely debated.
And we are hopeful that the
Massachusetts Legislature
will pass it.
But what's especially important
about Connecticut is that
when you look at a state like California,
California already had really good law.
So it didn't take them much
to get up to speed with this.
Connecticut's laws had not
been updated in decades.
And so our laws still
said, husband and wife,
even once we allowed
same-sex couples to marry,
we didn't change our parentage laws.
Our laws still talked about children,
quote, born out of wedlock.
I mean, terms that we don't use anymore.
And so there were various
ways in which our laws
just hadn't kept up.
We talked about artificial insemination
when assisted reproduction involves
a lot of different procedures now,
and so Connecticut badly needed this.
And the most important thing was that
Connecticut was the only
state in New England
that didn't have a path to parentage
for a non-biologic parent
in an unmarried couple.
And so people shouldn't
have to get married
in a order for their
parent-child relationships
to be recognized.
And that was a really important advance
in our law given how far
we had lagged behind.
- Yeah, thank you, Doug.
So we started with the
end, I'd like to go back
and have you talk with
us about the journey.
Can you talk with us about the process
of getting the law passed?
What was the process?
What was your role?
What role did others play?
- Yeah, so I guess I'll start by saying
I had recently moved to
Yale and it was actually
really amazing to me the ways in which,
coming from the university
allowed me to speak
to a lot of folks who are
decision makers in the state
and talk to them about this issue.
And I don't know, coming from California
that I had any similar
opportunities there.
So it was nice to be able to do that.
So I was teaching a course called
the constitution of the
family in the Law School
and started inviting,
I invited the new chair
from the Judiciary Committee
to come speak to the class,
invited the head of the
family law section of the bar
and then eventually we had
the person that ended up
being our Chief Legislative Sponsor,
Representative Jeff Currey,
who carries a lot of the LGBTQ legislation
in the State House.
And the students were
able to be a part of this
from the get go, which was really nice.
We partnered with GLAD, which
is LGBTQ public interest firm
that handles New England.
And so they were our main partner
and we created a coalition,
the Connecticut Parentage Act,
we called it the We Care
Coalition and it included
a range of organizations and
stakeholders in the state,
LGBT organizations, children's
rights organizations,
healthcare providers,
assisted reproduction groups,
fertility access advocacy
organizations, planned parenthood,
the ACLU, and really wanted to make sure
that we were building
this from the ground up
and working with stakeholders to make sure
we were able to show
lawmakers in the state
why this was really important
and also working with
state actors to make sure
we were getting buy-in and
then working with them.
So we worked very closely
with the probate court
and the judicial branch, as
well as with the state agencies
who deal with these matters,
like the Department of Social Services
and the Department of
Children and Families.
And we were derailed by the
pandemic in the 2020 session,
but we came back in 2021
and were able to pass it.
So the nicest thing was
that some of the students
who had started working on it
in their first year of Law
School were able to see it passed
in their third year of Law School
right before they graduated.
- And that's an amazing
accomplishment all around.
It was interesting to hear you itemize
the different communities
that came together,
but it's really an ecosystem.
So I'm wondering, have
you had other experiences
prior to this trying have a law
of change or to change laws?
- Yeah, so I've been very
focused on parentage.
So I have been involved with
some of the other efforts
in other states.
Connecticut was refreshing in that
it was a bit more substantive
than some of the experiences
we've had in other jurisdictions.
People were happy to get into the weeds
and we included people early on.
I'm involved in some legislative
of work that's happening
right now in Colorado.
And it's a scramble because
all the stakeholders
weren't there at the get go.
And so I found in Connecticut
we were able to get everyone
to the table early on and
really be able to be thoughtful
about how we were gonna do this
and make sure that there weren't folks
coming out of the woodwork
at the last minute saying,
well, what about me or I
haven't been consulted.
We really were exhaustive
and the legislators here
I think really appreciated that.
- Okay, fantastic.
As you were talking you're
really referencing culture change
in addition to behavior
change and mindset change.
We live in polarized times,
changing laws on parents
and children might seem
like a culture war issue.
I'm wondering if you
could talk with us about
how you actually managed
to get large communities,
large populations to come on board
to support this particular law.
And at the same, because I
heard you made a nice comparison
to another example of where
people weren't early adopters.
So could you talk a little
bit more about that process
and roles that you had taken on,
but also I imagine this is a
community building activity,
what other activities occurred?
- Yeah, so it was really
fascinating, I think for me,
but also for my students
who at the Law School,
we tend to be too focused
on federal systems.
We teach federal law primarily
and focused on the
Supreme Court in Congress
and the executive branch.
And this was about the state
and it was focused on
getting state lawmakers
in a heavily Democratic state,
but still one with a significant
Republican population
in the Legislature to see
this is an important issue.
And I think we were all really
heartened to see that people
were not just dug into their positions.
People were willing to
listen and be educated.
And many of the law had not
thought about this issue,
didn't know it was a problem,
but they were willing
to listen and be moved.
And one example just
sticks out in my mind.
In our first hearing in the 2020 session,
the ranking Republican
member on the Senate side
of the Judiciary Committee was there.
We had had a meeting with him in which
we told him what the bill was,
but we otherwise hadn't had
any other conversations with him,
but one of the families
testified and they were in tears
and he was in tears.
And he came over to us
after the hearing and said,
"I signed on as a co-sponsor
during that testimony."
And so nothing's more powerful, I think,
than hearing from families.
But you have to be willing to listen
and the legislators
were willing to listen.
And then the 2021 session,
there was a new House side
ranking member on the Judiciary Committee.
And he had founded the conservative caucus
in the Legislature.
And we were genuinely concerned that
it might be a obstacle for us.
We had meetings with him, he was a lawyer,
he understood the issues.
And at the end, even if
he wasn't necessarily,
for a lot of people the
importance of the LGBT
equality dimensions of this was huge.
He cared a lot about making
sure that children's lives
were respected and that we were protecting
their relationships and
he became a co-sponsor.
And when the Governor
signed the bill on PRIDE Day
in June of 2021, he was
there to witness that.
And so, I mean, it's
naive of me to think that
this has application in
a lot of other settings,
but it was nice to see that in our state,
people are still willing
to listen to each other.
And we had Republican
support from the get go
in both sessions.
And that was actually
really important for us
to be able to move the bill forward
and to have people understand
the importance of something like this.
- Yeah and I really value storytelling.
Kim in her introductory
remarks talked about
the last Belonging initiative,
which really focused
on telling your story.
So thank you for sharing that.
I'm wondering if there's
another side to this equation
and that's the lens of, either
resistance or opposition.
Did you experience any?
And if so, how'd you work either around it
or through it or conquer it?
- Yeah, so the depressing
thing to me was that
the most resistance were from
lawyers who don't like change.
And so the community
of lawyers who practice
in these cutting edge areas
of assisted reproduction
and LGBT family formation in the state,
it's a very small group
and they were wonderful
and helpful and supportive.
But the general population
of family lawyers,
it took more time to get them to a place
where they were comfort with this.
And I think for folks who are
the ones that are doing cases
and having, the bill is 177 pages long.
So people quite reasonably
don't like to have
to get up their seat, and even
with the courts were saying
we have to do new forms and the
Department of Public Health,
we have to do new kinds of forms here
and birth certificates.
And we have this very
important, what I take to be
maybe the most important part of the bill.
And that is we changed what
were previously under our law
called acknowledgements of paternity
to acknowledgements of parentage.
So under federal law,
every state is required
to have what they call
a hospital based system
of paternity registration.
And so that's the most
common way that paternity
is established for non-marital
children in the US.
And so if you go to Yale, New Haven
I think something like 40
to 50% of the births there
to unmarried women and something
like 70% of those cases,
paternity is being established
through signing the
acknowledgement of paternity.
The birth parent and the man who says
he's the biological
father sign it together,
it has the force of a judgment.
And so it establishes
paternity and has legal effect.
And what we did was change it
to an acknowledgement of parentage
and keep the same folks can sign it,
but also open it to same-sex couples
and others using assisted reproduction
that they could sign it to say,
they're an intended parent.
And we're now the 10th state to do that.
And the Department of Public Health
wasn't thrilled about this,
'cause they have forms
and computer systems.
And so really, it took
getting people to see
we're gonna do this and
so come along with us
so that we can make it
as painless as possible,
but it's gonna happen.
And it's important that it happens
and concerns about changing
forms or learning new law
are not sufficient reasons to not do this.
So that was where we had to
deal with the most resistance.
- Yeah, so let me move from
resistance to the word fear.
Were there any conversations
that you were a part of
or learned about where part of
the resistance may have been
someone's personal fear or in other cases,
maybe lack of knowledge about
this particular community
and the goals of this project?
- Yeah, so what's what was
interesting in Connecticut,
so I think in other states
the fact that it protects
LGBTQ families would be a problem
and there might be reasons not
to promote parentage reform
in that way.
In Connecticut, our
legislators and lots of people
in the state were actually eager,
they got it when we talk
talked about those families.
Yeah, my friend or my
neighbor had to do that
and they shouldn't have to do that,
but once you start digging into it,
so for instance, we have a provision in
there that allows a court to recognize
more than two parents for a child.
And that made some people
uneasy and I think it is fear.
And people started to say,
"Well, what if a heterosexual
identified man says,
'What if my wife divorces me
and gets married to another man
and he says he's the parent?'"
And you have to educate folks
on who these families are.
In my own research I study
some multi parent families
and courts actually are only doing this
when the person really is
the parent of the child
and it's not being used by
stepparents to assert parentage.
And so I think people get
worried when they think that
things are changing, but what
they sometimes fail to see
is things have already changed.
We just haven't really caught up to it.
And so these families all exist.
People might not think of them.
And sometimes they're the
most vulnerable families.
The reason there's a
third parent is often that
the biological parents
were facing challenges
that made it difficult to parent.
And so it's about protecting the children
in these families.
And I think having
people come back to that
and see that these families exist,
that's why the family
stories are so important,
helps deal with some of the fear,
which is just fear of the unknown
and fear of unintended consequences.
- Yeah, thank you, thank you.
I love the power of the storytelling.
You talked about different partners.
I'm wondering if we
could focus a little bit
on your law students.
You had partners in this
work, you led a clinic,
you referenced your law students.
Could you share with me and us
what the role of the
clinic was and specifically
the role that your law students played?
- Yeah, so I should start by
saying I'm not a clinician,
but Dean Gerken set an
example at the Law School
of those of us on the doctrinal side
being able to do clinics
when it intersects
with work we're doing.
And I was a practicing lawyer
before becoming an academic
and got licensed in
Connecticut to make sure
I could do this work.
And so I started a legislative
advocacy clinic on this
and had students working on
it across the three years
we were doing it, including
the two sessions in which
it was introduced.
Some of those students carried over.
So we had institutional memory
and they were able to lead
teams in the last year.
The really wonderful thing
is that at the Law School,
I had students who, before
coming to Law School,
their job was in public interest,
marketing and consulting
or communications.
And so we were able to really
have students with skill sets.
I'm not on social media at all.
So students who could run
the social media accounts,
students who could figure out how to do
certain kinds of communication
strategies and press releases
and get op-eds placed and
so that was wonderful.
And then we had students doing
more traditional legal work.
We needed to research things.
We needed to go through
the Connecticut statutes
and amend all of the
statutes that are affected
because there's a bunch of statutes
that use terms like paternity and limit.
So think of probate statutes,
we wanna make sure that
if someone dies that all of the children
we're having recognized
are gonna be treated
as legitimate children of the decedent.
And so we had to really do all of that
and students were tremendously helpful
and they also did a lot
of legislative advocacy,
so they helped with testimony,
they met with constituents and
really drove letter writing.
And so they were able to
see every dimension of it
and I hope really be able to do the work
that they were most passionate
about and get an experience
that they otherwise weren't gonna get.
Since most of the other
work they were exposed to
was really litigation type work
and this was something different,
but they were wonderful
and it made it so meaningful
to be able to get across
the finish line with them.
- And it sounds like an
amazing learning experience
that you don't often get
a chance to replicate
from year to year, so
it sounds very exciting.
So Doug, I started by saying
I've got five categories of questions.
I'm gonna switch us to my fourth category.
Which is about the law
and your scholarship.
You don't need to be a lawyer to know
that there's been a lot
of change in the law,
especially in the last 10 years
with regard to protections
for our lesbian, gay, bisexual,
transgender, queer community.
There seems to be more
and more protections.
But I know in Florida, which
I recently visited this year
and elsewhere there's current
attention to LGBTQ issues,
specifically in schools and in classrooms.
Can you say a bit about
the LGBTQ community
and the law and its impact
and some of the decisions
that some of our politicians are making?
Would love to hear your
perspective on that.
- Yeah, so unfortunately,
I mean, as you probably would guess,
parentage law in Florida's
also really dreadful
for LGBTQ people and parentage on Texas
is not good for LGBTQ people.
So there are zones like New England
where there's really equality
across multiple domains,
employment, parent-child
relationships, schools,
and then you get to other very
popular states like Florida
and Texas in which right
now in Florida or Texas,
if an unmarried lesbian
couple has a child together
and breaks up, only the biological
mother is a legal parent.
And in Texas, the courts were
even saying until recently
that a married lesbian couple
who had a child together
couldn't both be parents of that child,
even though we don't require
that men married to women
be a biological father.
So these are states where
I think LGBTQ people
and their families are
already feeling stigmatized
and facing discrimination.
The school's bills like
in Florida for instance,
are bad for children and bad for parents.
There are whether the law
recognizes them or not,
there are families that include
LGBTQ parents in Florida
and their kids are in school.
And we have the luxury in
Connecticut of being able
to talk to our schools about making sure
that their curriculum is
inclusive and reflects
the lives of the children
in the classroom.
And now in Florida, people
don't have that luxury
and those children are gonna get messages
that their families don't measure up.
And that's what we've been
fighting again for so long.
I mean, in Texas and
it's even more horrifying
given the Child Protective
Services order that parents
who are allowing their children
to have gender affirming
care are essentially deemed
to be committing child abuse or neglect.
And I mean these, in some
ways, it goes so much
against conservative ideas
about parental rights
and parental autonomy, it's
parental rights and autonomy
for some people and not for others.
And it's obviously not good for
children to be in situations
where not only is their emergent
identity being stigmatized,
but their are being told they can't,
the thing I said is so
important to parentage,
making decisions for your
child about healthcare,
they can't make those decisions
and protect their children.
So I mean, I'm in despair
about some of this stuff
but I also know we have
people who are working on it,
including folks at Yale and
at the Yale Child Study Center
who are trying to get people to understand
the stakes and see that
this is bad for families
and bad for children.
- Yeah, Doug, you use the word luxury
when you were responding
to the last question.
I have a note here where
early on you referenced
making New England a zone of equality.
I'm a native of New Haven,
which makes me a native of
Connecticut and still a resident.
And I have to say listening
to your talk and the outcome
of the collective effort
makes me proud to not just say
I'm a resident of New Haven
but certainly of Connecticut.
And so I'm thinking about
work through the lens
of both scholarship, but
also through a legal lens.
And then also the teaching and
exposure that you've created
for your students.
So scholarship can sometimes
be highly theoretical
dealing with the ideas rather
than the practical matters.
That might be the different at
a law school, maybe, I guess,
how do you see the relationship
between scholarship
and the changes in law?
Is there one?
And if so, what's your view?
- Yeah, so some of my
colleagues at the Law School
would certainly say I'm not
sufficiently theoretical.
So I will just start with that.
I care deeply about having
effects in the world.
And that's why I think a law school
is actually a really good
setting for some of the things
that I was most interested in.
I mean, my research church is
motivated by my commitments
to certain values and certain communities.
And so I found myself really focusing
on parent-child relationships
when I understood the harms.
And so for me, it's not
abstract or theoretical.
And so I was interested in
being able to show people
how the parentage framework
works to marginalize some people
and benefit others.
I think one could have
a fairly simplistic view
that just says, well,
non-biological parents,
because biology's what matters.
If you're not a biological parent,
you're all treated the
same, you have to adopt.
But what I tried to do in
my work is really dig down
into the frameworks of each state
'cause this is a state by state question
and see that that's not really true.
If you are a man married to a woman,
biology isn't everything.
And so it's some people who are being told
they have to adopt their own children.
And also biology has been
deemed more essential to women,
to motherhood than to men or fatherhood.
And so it carries forward ideas we've had
that it's women's natural
destiny to be mothers
and fathers can be
replaced by someone else.
And you see that even in the
way the law has developed.
And so it was much easier in
some states to get recognition
for non-biological mothers
in same-sex couples
because courts essentially
treated them like fathers.
They satisfied paternity presumptions,
but non-biologic fathers
in male same-sex couples
have had a much harder time.
And actually their hard time
has been like the experience
of non-biologic mothers
in different sex couples.
Because our law has had a
hard time saying that a woman
who doesn't give birth is a parent.
And so I've been motivated by
trying to get people to see
that the burdens of the
system don't fall evenly.
The other thing is that this work,
it is a feedback loop for
me, so doing this work,
the place that we encountered
the most resistance
was on what I called
functional parenthood.
And that is someone's a parent
because they have formed
a parent-child relationship,
we have requirements,
they have to reside with the child,
hold the child out as their child,
but they formed a
parent-child relationship.
They might have come into the child's life
when the child was one,
they weren't there when
the child was born,
but this is the child's parent.
And a lot of people resisted
that because they thought,
well, then anyone's gonna be a parent.
And biological parents
are gonna have to have
their rights infringed by these folks
who are really just mere
helpers who are coming in.
And it just didn't reflect
what I knew to be the families
who are affected by this.
And so a colleague of mine,
Courtney Jocelyn at UC Davis,
who does this work as well.
We decided to collect all of
the functional parent cases
in the 29 jurisdictions
that have these doctrines
and with a fabulous team of
research assistants at Yale,
code them and be able to
see what are the cases.
And then now we're taking that research,
so in Massachusetts the big resistance
is to the functional parent provision.
And the advocates at GLAD
are sending the draft article
and I'm in meetings telling them,
so for instance, in 83% of
these 600 plus cases we have
the person who's saying they
aren't functional parent
is the child's primary caregiver, right?
It's like a lot of families
facing a lot of challenges.
In 20% of the cases, no legal parent
has been a consistent
presence in the child's life.
So it's not what people envision.
It's not the step parent who's saying,
I wanna be a parent too,
it's actually families,
you get more of these cases
in places like Kentucky and West Virginia,
that sociologists are showing us
because of the opioid epidemic
a lot of children are not
residing with a legal parent.
And so someone else is parenting them.
And I guess the bigger push,
I mean the sense where I
do get more theoretical,
I want people to see that as parenting,
like that is not just caregiving,
parenting is a practice it's not a status.
- And it's an investment as well.
- Yes and it's hard work.
- Yes, I have two children
and I agree with that.
Doug, so one might look at
this accomplishment and say,
you're all done, I'm not sure you are.
So my next question is really about,
maybe it was about yesterday,
but I think it's written
as if we're looking into the future.
What's next?
And more importantly, what's next for you?
What else are you working on?
- Yeah, so I think, I mean, in some ways
the most basic thing
is getting more states
to treat people equally and
also getting other states
to respect what we're doing
in places like Connecticut.
I just had a call yesterday
with lawyers who say,
I can get a Connecticut judgment
and then I go to Alabama
and the Alabama Department
of Vital Records says,
I don't have to treat this or Tennessee,
the place we were talking
about was Tennessee,
I don't have to treat
this as a valid judgment,
I'm not giving you a birth certificate.
And so we need to really
focus on those questions
of people being able to
go across state lines
to hostile territory and
be treated as parents.
That's a big concern for people.
It's why people still adopt
even when they live in friendly states,
even though the adoption
decree should not be treated
differently than a judgment
or anything else that has a court order.
So that's one thing,
the things that follow
from passing parentage reform.
So for instance, there have
been folks in Connecticut
interested in changing
definitions of infertility
so that same sex couples and
single women would have access
to covered infertility treatment.
And I think you'll see
that continue to take off.
So assisted reproduction
has become a big focus.
And so there's also
something we did in our law,
but is just a start is
how are we gonna regulate that industry?
And how are we going
to provide information
to people who have donor conceived?
So making sure they get
their medical history,
that they have full information,
so I think that's really a next frontier.
And I think that's a tricky
one because I'm committed
to things like people should have access
to medical information,
and I'm also even committed to things like
people should be counseled
about the importance
of telling their children that
they were donor conceived,
about thinking about
whether they want a donor
who agrees to have their identity released
when the child is 18.
But I also think some of those discussions
tend to geneticize family relationships
in ways that are problematic
for my own work in LGBTQ families.
And so I think we need to be
clear that when we talk about
relationships created
through donor gamuts,
those are relationships that
could have different meanings,
but we shouldn't talk
about them as father,
biological fathers, parents.
I think its important and we
shouldn't be thinking that
children are harmed by not having
both biological parents raising them.
And so for me, I think an
important next bigger project
is just to get people to see that
biology doesn't make
parent-child relationships.
And in our current world of 23 and Me
where we're really fetishizing
ancestry and genetics,
it's important to be able
to get people to appreciate
that that's not all that family is.
- Yeah, thank you, so for our audience,
please feel free to type questions in.
I have just a couple more questions.
So trying to bring us a
little bit closer to closure.
This is my fifth and final
category and I've entitled it
advice and guidance,
it's kind of a two part.
So what should we all know
about parents and children in Connecticut?
First part and then the second is,
what should we tell our friends?
So I'm thinking specifically
as you started to describe
that ecosystem, what role can I play?
What role can other members
that are either going to watch
this recorded discussion
or are with us today?
What actions can we take
away from today's discussion?
- Yeah, so, I mean, I think
I hope people appreciate that
what a lot of folks take for granted,
other people spend a lot of time
and energy and money making clear.
And so I know people still think well, if,
and the one legislator
who voted against us,
he said on the House floor,
'Well, can't gay people just adopt?"
And that was the remedy for him.
And I will say like in European countries
increasingly I always say
they talk about adoption
as the remedy and here we
talk about it as the harm,
because you shouldn't have
to, I'm an adoptive parent,
but I didn't have to adopt my own child,
I adopted in the process
in which someone else
is the parent at birth,
but the folks that we're helping here
they're adopting their own kids,
no one else is saying they're
a parent to that child.
And so I think people need to experience
and appreciate that that is not something
parents should have to go through.
And so when we see that,
I think it starts to get us to see that
our social understandings of parenthood
probably should match
our legal understandings.
Because if you go to
communities around our state,
people are treating that
non-biological mother
in the same sex, couple like a parent,
the healthcare providers, the
school, the extended family,
the friends, the neighbors,
it's just the state that hasn't
been treating her that way.
And so our law should match
and family law, especially,
I think it's important.
we talk about the difference between
formal family law regimes and
functional family law regimes.
And I'm on the functional side.
I think our family law
systems should reflect
the way people live their lives
rather than trying to channel people
into particular forms of
family and relationship
by punishing people who don't conform.
And I think less conformity
around family arrangements
is not a bad thing
and we should meet people where they are.
- Where they're, thank
you, Doug, thank you.
So Doug, I can read one, I
see one question in the chat
and it's personal.
So the person said, "This is
a personal question for Doug.
And the question reads, how
do you organize your time
and keep energy for your scholarship
and life outside of
work with this advocacy?
Any tips on how you do that well?"
- I'm just exhausted
all the time, I think.
(both laughing)
So I have a three year old,
so that certainly takes a lot of time.
I mean, I fortunately have the luxury
of being at a law school
where at least my Dean
really supported this
work and appreciated it.
And so if I was a little
less in my scholarly writing,
I didn't feel like I was shirking,
but I will also say it was
an intense couple years
where as any time I had, I was
spending on this legislation.
And so I fortunately
was able to integrate it
into my teaching and so when
I say I taught a clinic,
I also got credit for teaching a clinic.
And so there were two semesters
where that was my course
load, teaching the clinic.
So it really allowed me
to focus on that work.
The other thing is I think the synergy
between the legislative advocacy
and my scholarship is helpful.
And so I wasn't writing about
things that I was learning
and getting interested in and
questions were being framed
by doing that legislative work.
And so for me, I was fortunate to have,
and so now it's spawned
this series of projects
with my co-author because we've
gotten so invested in this.
But yeah, I was really
happy when it passed
both because it helped so
many people in the state,
but also because it meant
I could finally take
the research leave that I'd been delaying
because I was working
on this all the time,
so it's not easy.
- Fantastic, I see another
question has popped in.
It says, "You mentioned
one of the testimonies
from the legislative process.
Can you share some other stories?"
- Yeah, so I assume meaning stories
that people told to lawmakers.
- That's my assumption.
- Yeah, so, I mean, actually we had,
one of the most amazing stories
was from a Yale Law School
student who was in my clinic
and she was born through
one of the first surrogacy
arrangements in the US
involving a male same-sex couple.
Her fathers lived in California,
they then moved to New
Mexico where she was raised.
And she's been involved with
an advocacy organization
called Collage,
which represents two
children of LGBTQ parents.
And she both got Collage on
board to support our bill
and now I've been working with them
and they're involved in the
Massachusetts effort as well,
but she also testified
and she testified about
what it was like to grow up
because she's a law student
and so things changed dramatically
and not have her non-biologic
father be her legal parent
to have for a lot of her life
the woman who was the surrogate,
be her legal mother on
her birth certificate.
And to also feel like people
didn't treat her family
as fully belonging.
And I had a Republican
legislator on the committee
call my cell phone after that and said,
"I don't know if you saw this testimony,
but it was the most amazing
thing I've ever seen."
And I could tell, he said by
her testimony that her fathers
did an incredible job raising her.
And then when we got to the Senate floor,
which was our last hurdle
before the Governor's signature,
our lead Senate sponsor gave a speech
in which she talked about
the student's testimony
and about her family.
And it was so great because
so much of the Law School
experience at Yale is about
being analytical and
making arguments in law
that persuade decision makers.
And she can do that,
but she also knew how to make an argument
that was persuasive for emotional reasons
and for personal reasons.
And it also, she started
crying during her testimony
and she talked to me afterwards and said,
"I didn't expect that,
I didn't think I was gonna be so moved
but telling this group of
lawmakers about my experience
was just more moving than
I imagined it to be."
And so it was things like that
I think that really stuck with me.
The other thing I'll just
say is there was testimony
by someone from the Family Law Section
of the Connecticut Bar in the
first session that we were in
and what she missed was
that right before her
was this family I talked
about with the de facto mother
who had been raising the
kid since he was three
and now he was 14, and
that had everyone in tears,
but this woman from the
bar wasn't there for that.
And so she just waltzed
in when they called her
and gave this testimony about
how bad defacto parentage was,
because suddenly anyone
was gonna be a parent,
you could have 100 parents
and these people aren't really parents
and the legislators just tore into her
and started saying like,
"You mean to tell me this?"
And then finally the
co-chair of judiciary,
the Senate side said,
'cause she then kept saying,
stepparents are gonna be parents.
And he said, "I'm a stepfather
and I'm the only thing
other my children know.
And you have to stop saying
that all stepparents are not parents."
So it really was just like
one, know your audience
and see what comes before you.
But two, it just showed how
people's actual experiences
can rebut some of these
arguments that are just about
assumptions from people
who don't really know
what people's family lives are like.
- Yeah and I love in that
story the change in role,
which the eye perspective that
you were describing, right?
Yeah, so automatically it became personal.
- Yes.
- I do think when things become personal,
I think that's when we can
make even more progress.
So Doug, I am trying to
keep my eye on the Q&A
and we have another question,
there was a comment where someone said,
thank you so very for today's talk.
So I will extend that gratitude to you.
The next question says, how
intersectional are issues
about parentage?
Do you run into questions of racism
and other forms of discrimination?
- Yeah, so it's a great question.
So certainly I think what
fail to realize is that
if you look at family demographics,
marital families and non-marital
families look different.
So we are in a world in
the US of marriage decline,
rates of marriage used to be high,
they've gotten lower and lower.
Rates of marriage used to be similar
across racial and ethnic groups,
but they now diverge significantly.
So African Americans and
Latinos are less likely
to be married than whites
and Asian Americans.
It's also stratified by class,
people with higher incomes
and more education are
more likely to be married.
And so for us a big part of
this was protecting parents
and children in non-marital families.
And so I think that does have
race and class dimensions.
And I think so that was
important to get people
to see that look you might think that
we're just sorting people based on,
are you a biological parent?
Are you a marital parent?
But that actually has a disparate impact
based on racing class.
There's also intersections
with immigration.
And so we did, one of the
sponsors, one of the members
of our coalition was an
immigration organization
because I'm sure you remember
early on in our efforts,
the Trump administration was separating
children at the border
and the federal government
decided they were gonna use
DNA tests to determine whether
people were actually parents of the child.
Well, to me, that's not determining
whether someone's actually
a parent of the child.
And in fact, they weren't even asking
whether the home jurisdiction
would treat them as a parent.
It was just sort of,
we decided this is what a
parent-child relationship is
and surprise, some of those
people were not genetic parents,
but they were the primary
caregivers of those children.
And so people saw the importance
of more expansive understandings
of family relationships
in the immigration setting as well.
- Doug, the last comment
that I see is just that,
it is another note of gratitude.
It says, thank you for this session.
I'm amazed at what I didn't know.
And you have shed some light
around unanswered questions that I had.
And so I'm gonna take to a close
and first I'm gonna
practice gratitude as well.
And I wanna say, thank you.
My thank you are probably
a little bit different.
Mine is a selfish thank you.
Because at the beginning you
said you moved to Connecticut.
So let me say very selfishly,
I'm so glad that you live in Connecticut
and that we are working
towards creating a region
where there is equality.
But when I start to think about the state
that I'm living in,
it's really nice to know
that we're making positive movement
towards creating a world of inclusion.
So I'm selfishly saying thank you
and hope you stay in
Connecticut for quite some time
to transform our state and us as people.
You used the word we decided.
And so I'm gonna switch
that to, I decided,
I decided that I'm gonna
close out by saying,
you rock and thank you so much
for all of your time today,
but I think that thank you
also needs to be extended
to the team of individuals that
you've constantly itemized,
as you were answering questions
that are part of that village
that is helping to make change
in Connecticut and also in other states
where change is certainly necessary.
I just want to close with one question
and mine is around
hopefulness, as you think about
the progress that's been
made within our state
and then you look outside of
Connecticut, US and beyond,
are you hopeful that
in maybe this lifetime,
your lifetime or your child's lifetime,
that we as a society will
become much more inclusive
and practice more equity?
- Yeah, so I mean, things are
really depressing right now.
And I'm a co-author on a case book
on sexuality and gender
identity and the law
and we're doing a new addition.
And my co-author was saying like,
if you went back to 10 years ago
and actually the author
who started the book
in the early '90s said
no idea that these issues
I wrote about then were
gonna be the main issues now.
It was anti-gay curriculum laws,
so that leaves me with a lot of worry.
But I also think that the
experience here has shown that
people who are willing
to listen can be moved
and that people care about their neighbors
and family members and
more and more people
are going to be living
in family arrangements
that don't look like their
parents' family arrangements.
And I'm an example of having parents
who come around to understanding
the importance of respecting people,
even if they don't conform to
what your life looked like.
And so I do have some optimism around that
and seeing the kids in
Florida and Texas push back
also gives me optimism.
- Yeah, I agree.
And our advocates are becoming younger
and younger and younger,
which I think is fantastic
and using their voice, not finding it,
but using their voice.
So I'm gonna close out again
by saying thank you very much.
And thank you to all of the
attendees for today's webinar.
Brief reminder that
Belonging at Yale website
has a calendar of upcoming
events on topics that
enhance diversity, support equity,
and promote a welcoming environment
and inclusive environment here at Yale.
Thank you, Doug, for
spending your afternoon
and almost a little bit
of your evening with us
and everyone else, thank you so much
and have a great evening and
a great weekend, take care.
- Thank you.